this morning we're introducing you to a
talented artist who says he won't let
anything stop him from creating art
these are the works of desmond blair
some of which were featured in an
exhibit at a north texas gallery this
summer his work though is partly
inspired by a unique circumstance some
would regard as a disadvantage but which
he used as a strength although he was
born with immense creativity he was also
born without hands omar villafranca
introduces us to blair and his
work every stroke of desmond blair's
brush i know where i'm blocking my
lights my shadows brings a rich and
beautiful subject to life on canvas just
kind of contours where those happen at
the way he paints eyes and the vivid
details of light in his portraits hint
at the years he's been practicing his
craft but his dedication and how the 35
year old handles a brush
is a work of art in itself part of it
was because the way i was born uh so
since i was born without hands it's just
like
people would tell me what i wouldn't be
able to do but it's like if i had a
sheet of paper and like a pilot pen
like you're not gonna take that away
from me and if you do i can just go get
another one
and so the same thing once i started
painting and doing other things it's
just like
you can say what you want but i'm still
going to go buy canvas i'm still going
to keep painting blair was born without
hands caused by a genetic mutation
growing up in dallas his mother and
grandmother encouraged and pushed him to
find his own way to do things your
journey is going to be different and we
have to figure this out and so it was
always that mindset
of
you know
i still expect excellence but we got to
figure out how to get there at school he
had to get creative to learn how to
write with a pencil but when the art bug
bit blair in an early age he taught
himself how to handle crayons with his
wrists and explore his gift we tried a
bunch of different things like putting
crayons in my mouth holding crayons with
my feet so um i figured out how to write
that's the writing side that's for you
to be this you know desmond the student
yeah what was it about crayons that
triggered desmond the artist i watched
cartoons and so i wanted to learn how to
draw the characters in the cartoons as a
kid his mom enrolled him in a summer art
program in dallas there he met one of
his mentors emmanuel gillespie i think
everyone has that creative ability but
he had that passion anyone can do it but
that's the passion that drives it from
crayons blair turned to acrylics then to
oil
in college his talent grew as did his
skill and more than 25 years later this
is the first one
in the series
his first public exhibit at dallas's
pencil on paper gallery owned by his
biggest supporter gillespie and his wife
valerie i think when people would look
at this
they they focus on the art
and they see you and they're like okay
here's the artist but they're always
drawn to the fact that you don't have
hands yeah
how do you balance that and say no no
look at that not me that
i look at it as an opportunity to
educate people about limb differences
his collection is titled in the garden
and features black women as eve in the
famous biblical story we have desmond
portraying us in this beautiful light he
captures our essence our skin our
mannerisms everything just stunningly
he sees us and he appreciates us and he
translates that onto canvas so all of us
can see his next project will be
difficult and personal he plans to paint
his muse and motivation joyce blair his
mother
she passed away in 2020 after a battle
with als
i wanted to make sure i was in the right
space in place to be able to do it it
would be like a full circle moment
because the things that she taught me
growing up as she advanced with her
disease
it was just like okay we've done this
before
we've learned how to adapt art is meant
to inspire others
but sometimes the artist is a
masterpiece
for cbs morning's omar villafranca
dallas
that was good omar a nice way to end it
sometimes nate the art
is the master the artist is a
masterpiece i love that the influence of
his mother and his grandmother who said
despite everything that's happened to
him they still expect excellence yeah
and he's still doing the detail in his
work detail and when he was younger
putting him in that art camp yeah saying
regardless of what my son is dealing
with
not having hands we want to put him in
something that he's passionate for look
where he's at now bravo desmond